Stephen is in North Carolina hi Stephen
how are you go whoa Dave Halbach so good
man how can we help
hey Dave so all right so I am 23 years
old a year remove of graduating with a
public health degree right now I have a
car it's actually my first car to 2004
Toyota Corolla
problem there's hasn't really give me
any problems but it's on steroids
I currently have right now $8,000 saved
up a my savings account and I've always
been on the mindset that my next car I
was gonna pay out cash for it so now the
dilemma is I also have a thirty two
dollars two thirty two thousand dollars
worth of student loan but I will I'm
playing on going into grad school within
the next year so should I just take that
money my savings and pay off or pay
towards my student loan now while
there's no interest or should I just go
out and try to find the car before
getting into grad school at all good
stuff Steven let me ask you this
question why are you going to grad
school do you need it for the particular
career field you're going into or do you
just want to go into it right now well
right now I'm currently not using my
bachelor's degree at all I'm trying to
get into nursing school um particularly
direct entry like the Masters of Nursing
um I'm not I'm not getting anything me
I'm not making anything yet what I want
to make in life so understand this
opportunity to try and correct whatever
wrongs I probably done well in my time
at my university and why and when you go
to to school to get your nursing degree
are you paying for a cash no I'll be
taking out more loans yeah so the
thought is so I just decrease the total
hit at the end now for the sake of
living the rest of my life a little bit
easier no no no no I don't like the fact
you say you
take out more loans to go back to school
so my thing is right now we need to
actually sit down and get a plan to get
a vision to where okay here's where I'm
at here's where I want to go how do I
get there without racking up any more
debt I have no problem with you going to
get you know your nursing degree so you
can get into that field I have a problem
with you racking up debt for that so my
thing is how do we cash flow that okay
that's gonna be the first thing but then
at the same time you're 23 sitting with
35 thousands worth of debt
the car is not really an issue right now
the thing is one how did we get out of
this debt - do I have a job do you have
a current job right now
yes well right now I'm a stretch
therapist and also I do sports
performance training and and how much
are you making a year altogether
probably around 30 oh that's good yeah
yeah so Anthony's right the first step
to getting out of debt is don't borrow
any more so the $8,000 you have safe
goes towards your nursing degree and
scratching up more money working more
living on nothing and no you don't move
up in car and then turn around take out
student loans because you know any money
so we're gonna drive that car through
that you got the nursing school
and you need to gather up as many
scholarships as you can work as make
jobs as you can and let's pile up cash
and finish up this degree that you're
looking for with cash the cash you've
got plus the cash we scraped together
hold on we're going to send you a copy
of Anthony's book debt-free degree
Kelley I'll pick up and get that done
for you